okay now we're going to talk about the
supervised learning problem and set down
a little bit of notation
so we'll have an outcome measurement y
which is goes by various names dependent
variable response or target and then
we'll have a vector of p predictor
measurements which are usually called x
they go by the name inputs regressors
covariates
features or independent variables
and we distinguish two cases one is the
regression problem y is quantitative
such as price or blood pressure
in the classification problem y takes
values in a in a finite unordered set
such as survived or died the digit class
is zero to nine the cancer class of the
tissue sample
now we have training data pairs x1 y1 x2
y2 up to xn yn so again x1 is a vector
of p measurements y1 is usually a single
response variable and so these are
examples or instances
of these measurements
so the objectives of supervised learning
is as follows on the basis of the
training data we would like to
accurately predict unseen test cases
understand which inputs affect the
outcome and how
and also to assess the quality of our
predictions and the inferences
so by way of philosophy as you take this
course we want
not just to give you a laundry list of
methods but we want you
to know that it's important to
understand the ideas behind the various
techniques so you know where and when to
use them because in your own work
you're going to have problems that we've
never seen before you've never seen
before and you want to be able to judge
which methods are likely to work well
which ones are not likely to work well
as well uh
not just prediction accuracy is
important but it's it's important to to
to try simple methods first in order to
grasp the more sophisticated ones we're
going to spend quite a bit of time on on
linear models linear regression and
linear logistic regression these are
simple methods but they're very
effective
and it's also important to understand
how well method is doing right it's easy
to apply an algorithm you can nowadays
you can just run software but
it's it's difficult but also very
important to figure out how methods is
how well is the method actually working
so you can tell your boss or your
collaborator that when you apply this
method we've developed this is how
likely how well you're likely to do
tomorrow and and in some cases you won't
do well enough to actually use the
method and you'll have to improve your
algorithm or maybe collect better data
another other thing we want to convey
just through the course and hopefully
through
the examples is that this is a really
exciting exciting area in research i
mean statistics in general is very hot
area cisco learning and machine learning
is of more and more importance and it's
really exciting that the area is not in
it gelled in any way in the sense that
there's a lot of good methods out there
but a lot of challenging problems that
aren't solved so especially in in recent
years rob you know with the onset of big
data and
and and coined the word data science
right and uh physical learning as trevor
mentioned is a fundamental ingredient in
the in this new area of data science
so you might be wondering where where's
the term supervised and
supervised learning come from it's
actually a very clever term and i'd like
to take credit for it but i can't it
wasn't it was developed by someone in
the i think in the in the machine
learning area that he has supervisor and
he can think in a kindergarten of a
teacher trying to teach a child to
classify to to discriminate between what
a say a house is in a bike so he might
show the child maybe johnny say
uh johnny here's here's some examples of
what a house looks like it may be in in
in lego blocks and here's some examples
of what what a bike looks like
so and you see and
he tells johnny this and shows him
examples of each of the classes and then
the child then learns oh i see a house
has got sort of square edges and a bike
has got some more rounded edges etc
that's supervised learning because he's
been given examples of label training
observations he's been supervised
and and as trevor just sketched out in
on the previous slide
the y there is given and the the child
tries to learn the to classify the two
objects based on the features the x's
now um
unsupervised learning is another
thing topic of this course and which i
grew up
i see that's the problem okay well so in
unsupervised learning now in the
kindergarten not trevor's in
kindergarten and the child was not
trevor was not given examples of what a
house in a bike was he's he just sees on
the ground lots lots of things right he
sees maybe some houses some bikes some
other things
and so this this data is unlabeled
there's no why oh it's pretty sharp bro
okay so um the problem there now is for
the child just it's unsupervised to try
to organize in his own mind the common
patterns of what he sees right he may
look at the object and say oh these
three things are probably houses or he
doesn't know they're called houses but
they they're similar to each other
because they have common features these
other objects maybe their bikes or other
things they're similar to each other
because i see some commonality
and
that brings the idea of trying to group
observations by similarity of features
which is going to be a
a major topic of this course
unsupervised learning
so more formally again there's no
outcome variable measure just a set of
predictors and the objective is more
fuzzy it's sort of it's not just it's
not to predict why because there is no
why it's rather to learn about the how
the data is organized
and to find which features are important
for the organization of the data so
we'll talk about again clustering and
principal components which are important
techniques for unsupervised learning one
of the other challenges is
is that it's hard to know how well
you're doing right there's no gold
standard there's no why so when you've
done a clustering
analysis you don't really know how well
you've done
and that's one of the challenges but
nonetheless it's an extremely important
area
both because well one reason is that the
idea of unsupervised learning is an
important preprocessor for supervised
learning it's often useful to try to
organize your features choose features
based on on the um
on the on the x's themselves and then
use those those processed or chosen
features as input into supervised
learning and the last point is that it's
a lot easier it's a lot more common to
collect data which is unlabeled right
because on the web for example if you
look at movie reviews you can you can
a computer algorithm can just scan the
web and grab reviews
figuring out whether review on the other
hand is positive or negative often takes
human intervention so it's much harder
and costly to label data much easier
just to collect unsupervised unlabeled
data
well the last example we're going to
show you is a wonderful example it's a
netflix prize
netflix is a
movie rental company in in the us
and now you can get the movies online
they used to be
see dvds that were mailed out
and
netflix set up a competition
to try and improve on their recommender
system so they created a data set with
400 000 netflix customers
and 18 000 movies
and each of these customers had rated on
average around 200 movies each so
so each customer had not seen
they've only seen about one percent of
the of the movies
and so you can think of this as having a
a very big matrix
which is very sparsely populated with
ratings between one and five and then
the goal is to try and predict as in all
recommender systems to predict what the
customers would think of the other
movies based on what they rated so far
so netflix set up a competition
um which
where they offered a one million dollar
prize for the first team that could
improve on their
on their rating system by 10 percent
by some measure and the design of the
competition was very clever i don't know
if it was by by luck or not but the the
root mean square error of the original
algorithm was about 9.953 so that's on a
scale of again one to five
and it took the community when they
announced the the competition and put
the data on the web it took the
community about about a month or so to
get to have an algorithm which improved
upon that
but then it took the community about
another three years to actually for
someone to win the competition
so it's a it's a it's a great example
here's the leaderboard um at the time
the competition ended it was with it was
eventually won by a team called bell
course pragmatic chaos
um but a very close second was ensemble
in fact they had the same score up to
four decimal points um and and the final
winner was determined by who submitted
the the final predictions first
and so this was a wonderful competition
but what was especially wonderful was
the amount of research that it generated
there were thousands tens of thousands
of teams all over the world entered this
competition over the period of of three
years and a whole lot of new techniques
were invented in the process
a lot of the winning techniques ended up
using a form of
principal components in the presence of
missing data how come our names not on
that list trevor where's our team
that's a good point rob
the page isn't long enough
i think if we went down a few hundred
you might
so actually seriously we actually tried
with a graduate student when the
competition started we spent about three
or four months
trying to trying to win the competition
and
one of the problems with was computation
the data was so big and our computers
were not fast enough to just to try
things out took too long and we realized
that the graduate student
um was probably not going to succeed and
he was probably going to waste three
years of his graduate program which is
not a good idea for his career so we
we basically abandoned ship early on
so i mentioned the beginning of the idea
of the field of machine learning which
actually
led to
the
statistical learning area which we're
talking about in this course
and machine learning say itself arose as
a subfield of artificial intelligence
especially with the advent of neural
networks in the 80s
so it's natural to wonder what's the
relationship between statistical
learning and machine learning and
there's it's first of all the question's
hard to answer we ask that question
often there's a lot of overlap machine
learning tends to work at larger scales
they tend to work on bigger problems
although again the gap tends to be
closing because computers fast computers
now becoming much cheaper
machine learning worries more about pure
prediction and how well things predict
cisco learning also worries about
prediction but but also about
models tries to come up with models
methods that can be interpreted by
scientists and others and also um
by how well the method is doing we worry
more about precision uncertainty
but again the distinctions become more
and more blurred and there's a lot of
cross-fertilization between the methods
machine learning clearly has the upper
hand in marketing
they tend to get much bigger grants and
their their conferences are much nicer
places but
we're trying to change that starting
with this course
so
here's the course text
introduction to statistical learning
we're very excited this is a new book um
by two of our graduate students past
graduate students gareth james and
daniella witten and robin myself book
just came out in in august 2013 and this
course will cover this book in its
entirety
the book has
as at the end of each chapter there's
examples run through in in the r
computing language
and we we do sessions on r and so when
you do this course you'll actually learn
to use r as well r is a wonderful
environment it's free
and
and it's a really nice way of doing data
analysis
you'll see there's a second book there
which is our
more advanced textbook elements of
statistical learning that's been around
for a while
that that would be serve as a reference
book for this course for people who want
to understand some of the techniques in
in more detail now the nice thing is
this court not only is this course free
but these books are free as well
the elements of statistical learning has
been free and and the pdfs available on
our websites this new book is going to
be free beginning of january when the
course begins
and uh and that's a with agreement with
the um with the publishers but if you
want to buy the book that's okay too
it's nice having the hard copy but if
you want the pdf is available
so
um we hope you enjoy the rest of the
class